votre rédacteur en chef m'a contacté
par rapport à Benjamin Castaldi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
franchement
je viens en famille vraiment mon
objectif c'est d'optimiser les gens par
de vous faire de la peine ou voilà donc
il est pas là pour vous enfoncer au
contraire merci restons s'il vous plaît
cordiaux voilà ce Castel dit comme ça on
peut travailler ensemble faire une
petite séquence si je peux transmettre
un petit peu de mon art et de ma passion
c'est vrai qu'il y a un qui arrive merci
incroyable Stéphane alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est que votre rédacteur
m'a dit qu'il y a une émission que j'ai
regardé du coup pour analyser j'ai fait
mon petit travail en amont 20 secondes
de temps de parole sur une émission pas
de bêtises on est d'accord hein c'est
laquelle euh c'était c'était une grande
émission 20 secondes de temps de parole
donc j'ai analysé un petit peu la
situation sur ces 20 secondes c'est à
dire que déjà là j'ai plus parlé que
Benjamin Castel
déjà là là j'ai plus bossé que vous donc
voyez je suis là moi je suis dur je sais
je suis dur c'est aussi la manière de
fonctionner vous l'avez connu à la fin
comme Mathieu Rambo
Benjamin pour régler un problème il faut
mettre le doigt sur ce problème sur ces
20 secondes d'intervention il y a 10
secondes
qui sont peu compréhensibles
et ça vous ça vous en parlez assez
souvent et des 10 autres secondes ne
sont pas percutants moi c'est ce que
j'apprends à mes élèves quand on prend
la parole quand on prend la parole il
faut toujours avoir en tête l'idée qu'on
va dire quelque chose qui va changer le
monde c'est ça une prise de parole
charismatique ici ça risque pas
excuse-moi
et d'ailleurs Benjamin regardez-moi
alors c'est compliqué
j'ai regardé un petit peu l'évolution de
votre carrière vous étiez comme une
immense c'est toujours une immense star
c'est toujours c'est toujours une
immense star c'est toujours alors est-ce
qu'on peut rentrer dans la pratique
voilà alors déjà par rapport au bilan
c'est intéressant vous n'êtes pas de son
regard vous moquez souvent de ces petits
yeux j'ai vu dans l'émission j'ai
regardé pas mal vraiment
monsieur Castel dit sur terre est-ce que
vous aviez c'est même petit yeux
répondre Benjamin réponds
pas tout à fait non j'ai regardé les
images les ai comparés j'ai mis deux
images côte à côte au fil de votre
carrière votre carrière a décliné vos
yeux sont devenus petits
[Rires]
il fera ça toutes les semaines sur un
chroniqueur
j'ai regardé un petit peu les emails
[Applaudissements]
une autre émission si vous voulez mais
j'aurai des choses à vous dire aussi
vous êtes un petit peu
vos prises de parole sont très efficaces
contrairement à Benjamin j'ai un petit
peu analysé tout ça je vous donnerai un
petit conseil tout simple puisqu'on est
là aussi pour donner des petites astuces
quand on a vous votre problème c'est la
voir j'envoyais aussi c'est vrai que
vous avez une voix compliquée en général
les gens compensent par leur physique
[Applaudissements]
le but n'est pas d'être méchant pas du
tout
exactement et c'est le monde dans lequel
on vit aujourd'hui on confond la
méchanceté et la volonté et je ne suis
pas là je vais vous donner un conseil
quand on a c'est ce que je dis souvent à
mes élèves quand on a un physique comme
le vôtre on ne propose pas on impose
[Applaudissements]
on va forcément vous dire non
est-ce que vous avez d'autres personnes
ici alors moi j'ai pas eu le temps parce
qu'on m'a prévenu assez tard j'ai plus
bosser sur Benjamin mais qui n'accepte
pas le jeu on va dire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
est-ce que vous acceptez un petit cours
un petit peu
rire non non t'inquiète pas alors alors
ce que j'étais en train de vous dire si
vous me laissez alors selon vous déjà
qu'est-ce quelles sont les pistes il y a
un test qui a été fait aux États-Unis
s'appelle le test des lunettes d'accord
donc je vais vous essayer de manière de
juger vous pouvez même le faire chez
vous tout le monde peut le faire vous
vous prenez une paire de lunettes je
vais vous donner ça
c'est moi qui me qui vient vous vous
venez comment on fait
une paire de lunettes un mouchoir ok et
vous allez
essuyer ces lunettes et je vais en
fonction de ces gestuelles vous faire un
petit retour sur ce qu'on appelle le
charisme et ça alors c'est pas mal ça je
teste on peut le faire chez soi bien sûr
tout le monde peut le faire
voilà donc vous avez remarqué que
Benjamin Castaldi c'est flagrant toute
façon et c'est pas étonnant Benjamin
Castaldi quand il essuie ses lunettes il
regarde ses lunettes il regarde ses
limites
Benjamin c'est les victimes qui baissent
les yeux
[Rires]
ce qu'on fait on a pas besoin de
regarder ce qu'on fait est-ce qu'un
chauffeur de bus Benjamin regarde son
volant quand il veut
[Applaudissements]
regarde son volant
là vous venez de me prouver en une
action en un geste que vous êtes dans
une situation de votre vie où vous ne
maîtrisez pas ce que vous faites vous ne
contrôlez pas la situation ce qui
n'était pas le cas il y a 20 ans quand
je regarde les images de vous à la
télévision c'est tout ce que je voulais
vous dire si vous voulez prendre en
considération mes propos je vous invite
donc moi ce que je vous propose c'est
d'un jour venir dans ma salle et faire
une vraie séance avec moi d'une heure on
bosse ensemble tous les deux et vous me
disent à la fin ce que vous pensez et je
suis sûr vous aurez un autre regard sur
mon travail et je suis sûr que Cyril
vous aurez un autre chroniqueur dans
votre émission je peux vous l'assurer je
peux vous l'assurer
allez on Boris de l'huile je mets ma
crédibilité
des questions à Stéphane oui peut-être
Stéphane à votre avis on lève pas la
main pour pour poser une question
de poser une question pose la question
que c'est un maître comme vous d'accord
mais de cérémonie Stéphane à votre avis
autour de la table naturellement hormis
bien sûr au grand Cyril qui est le plus
de charisme honnêtement moi je ne vois
que Cyril non je peux pas vous dire
hormis lui c'est tellement flagrant
c'est tellement évident tu me diras on
est dans le même bois avec ça même moi
on est fait dans le même bois on est des
entrepreneurs on sait ce que c'est de
diriger un navire de regarder tous dans
la même direction il faut lui faire
confiance à ce type là mais ça c'est
fait mais il y en a pas autour de la
table qui est un peu de charisme très
honnêtement je sais ce que vous attendez
que je dis j'attends
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la première chose que je me dis en
voyant Mathieu peut-être la première
chose que vous dites comme vous le voyez
c'est quoi il est amusant d'accord
il faut pas confondre beauté car ils
sont ah ça c'est quelque chose qui
revient souvent quelqu'un est beau
quelqu'un qui respecte donc c'est faux
vous êtes très belle madame mademoiselle
je ne sais pas mademoiselle mais vous
n'êtes pas charismatique
vous êtes du Nord
je vous connais pas suffisamment mais en
voyant comme ça je vous me faites penser
un petit peu à ma boulangère vous avez
quelque chose
[Applaudissements]
elle nourrit le monde
accessible mais quelqu'un de
charismatique n'est pas accessible
américaine alors Béatrice je vous cache
pas que le prénom ça compte aussi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas ce que vous devez mettre en
premier en avant votre prénom
[Rires]
Daniel vous avez déjà de votre avis
c'est non c'est normal ou pas
bonsoir bonsoir Géraldine
florilège de prénom
et en 202
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la tenue vestimentaire ça compte aussi
quel âge avez-vous monsieur 31 ans 31
ans et vous habiller comme adolescent de
15 ans
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]